well the New York Times in case you
don't read it still being published
still out of New York ran a piece the
other day with this headline alarm
denial blame the pro-trump media's
coronavirus distortion they hit the same
themes in the telling of the New York
Times coronavirus coverage on this show
and elsewhere
followed a certain pattern the pattern
they told us went this way step one
blame China according to New York Times
quote when the virus ravaged China some
pundits on the right one did the country
couldn't be trusted to contain the
outbreak or share accurate information
about where it originated can you
believe they thought that were they get
that idea because it's true
but the New York Times does it admit
that then step two playing down the
risks followed by step three share
survivor stories to show the fire virus
wasn't so bad and finally step four
blame the left now as you're aware from
watching this program and from living in
this country whatever these people
accuse you of doing is 100% of the time
exactly what they're doing themselves
and that of course was the case here as
you know the establishment press has
been screwing up coronavirus stories
from day one so there are four steps to
understanding their coverage and here's
what they are the first step as usual
blame racism here are two New York Times
headlines in the early days of the
outbreak quote an outbreak of racist
sentiment as Crona virus reaches
Australia in other words people's bad
opinions are worse than a pandemic hmm
here's another in Europe fear spreads
faster than the krona virus itself
okay so then as the virus kept spreading
there was stepped to play down the risks
which the New York Times assiduously did
on January 29th the paper warns you to
quote beware the pandemic panic calm
down ladies and gentlemen a week later
they asked who says it's not safe to
travel to China look a ticket to Wuhan
racist somehow telling the public that
Crona virus was no big deal didn't in
the end contain the virus so The Times
went to step three politicize the crisis
calling the coronavirus the Chinese
virus of the Wuhan viruses bigotry the
paper will tell you but they had no
problem on February 26th publishing an
op-ed saying quote let's call it Trump
virus and then last week in a shameful
moment that
we'll live forever in infamy the paper
declared a time quoting the road to
coronavirus hell was paved by
evangelicals yeah that's right a
pandemic that emerge from an atheist
country is really the fault of
Christians as the New York Times that
tells you a lot about where they are and
now this week the paper is settled on
its favorite step step for blame Fox
News of course because there's a
political strategy here last week they
warned about quote Fox's fake news
contagion then there was yesterday's
article talk about a lie the show is
telling about the dangers of this
disease way back in January when the
times was still wondering if it was
racist to even know it existed and
encouraging you to travel to Wuhan on
vacation now we're highlighting the
continued dishonesty and malevolence of
China meanwhile the New York Times in
The Star reporter Donald McNeil is going
over to MSNBC to deliver unpaid
infomercials for the Chinese Communist
Party watch this in China there are
40,000 doctors nurses and respiratory
technicians went from all over China to
Wuhan and help the Wuhan doctors fight
the violence there's no more virus move
on those doctors are all gone home there
have been victory parades for them
gratitude flowers and everything they're
heroes they not only have the skills a
lot of them caught the virus and are now
immune so they can do a lot of things
that would be dangerous for somebody who
hasn't got the virus to do it I don't
see why we couldn't hire for our
pandemic a lot of those doctors nurses
respiratory technicians so if you're
Donald's McNeil's editor and you're
watching this aren't you calling it you
know his supervisor saying bring McNeal
and ease he's giving away the truth what
a she'll bring in Chinese doctors to run
our Hospital that's his take it's not
surprising though apparently Chinese
doctors already run the New York Times
well the new unemployment figures are
horrifying they're the largest in
American history almost by an order of
magnitude in two weeks 10 million people
have lost their jobs even more jobs will
be lost soon